Harvey Weinstein cuts a very different
figure these days from the man who once
be strode Hollywood arriving with the
aid of a walking frame for a trial on
charges of rape and sexual assault if
convicted he could be jailed for life
outside caught some of the dozens of
women who've made allegations against
him here to show their support for the
victims in court they are gonna be so
traumatized by going through this trial
and I can't even imagine I never got
that day in court maybe I was lucky but
I hope to god they prevail and I hope
justice is served when I got here this
morning I felt more settled and when he
walked out of the car and we were able
to stand there in our strength and just
look at him and see that he couldn't
even bear to make eye contact with us it
was a really powerful moment it made it
very clear that we hold the power here
we hold the strength here and he really
can't hurt us anymore Harvey Weinstein
is facing charges relating to two women
but some of the others who've made
allegations against him will also give
evidence to this trial to show what
prosecutors say is a pattern of behavior
in support of the most serious charge
against him that of predatory sexual
assault Weinstein was once a fixture on
the red carpets a celebrated producer an
Oscar winner who could make careers in
the movie business
then came the allegations that revealed
a dark side to the glamour it gave rise
to the me too and time's up campaigns on
the red carpets stars dressed in black
as a show of support for victims in this
industry and beyond in public at least
Weinstein's ignored questions about the
allegations against him do you believe
all of those women are lying
do you believe they're lying but others
have been more vocal his appearance in
the audience at an event for young
actors in October prompting this
reaction from some of those there Harvey
Weinstein has pleaded not guilty to the
charges he faces he recently said he
should be remembered for helping female
actors and directors not for the
allegations against him his accusers
said he should be remembered as a man
who took everything
deserve nothing it will be a jury that
decides Harvey Weinstein's fate Gregg
Milam Sky News New York